Have you ever been told, because you're a girl, that you should not do something?
Yes.
All the time.
It's a constant.
I want you to go grab one of those boxes over there.
This represents your limitation.
So I'd like you to write on each one, one of the things that you said.
I told myself that I should stop if I'm not good.
And did you quit?
For a week.
And then what happened?
I proved them wrong by trying harder to get better.
I think that you need to keep going with whatever you love to do...
...and do anything you want.
You can conquer any fear you've had and just live your dream...
...and do whatever you want to do and...
That's why I love the word "unstoppable."